and Robert Downey jr.
yeah I think we're supposed to be here
now okay hi so how are you oh I'm
nervous what do you think this is the
Academy Awards I've been nervous all
week wondering what am I gonna wear um
how am I gonna pronounce all these names
what about my makeup yeah mm-hmm your
makeup looks good tonight by the way
ripp well it sucks it's not supposed to
look like I'm wearing any well you know
all actors wear makeup just a lot of us
try to look like we don't have it on
yeah well it's no secret that we all
wear it but there's makeup and there's
makeup
there's the makeup that civil and I are
wearing and then there's the special
makeup that you'll see these actors were
in beetlejuice this was Michael Keaton
and his friend who used to have a
swelled head
created by V Neil Steve Laporte and
Robert short we're helping to change
Eddie Murphy and Arsenio Hall to so many
different characters cuts down on the
number of actors you have to employ I'm
just kidding
Rick bang
in Scrooged divisions that bill murray
saw were so horrible that he was forced
to mend his ways visions by Tom Burman
and Barry drivin Berman and the Oscar
goes to got a minute
and the Oscar goes to be Neal Steve
Letarte and Robert
we'd like to thank members of the
Academy our producer Richard Hashimoto
our director Tim Burton Michael Keaton
for bringing that wild and wacky
character Beetlejuice to life our hair
stylist Yolanda to sing and a cast of
many other makeup artists ed Enriquez
market with Sarah Mike Mills Frank kara
Sousa and many others and thank you to
the Academy for the great honor that
we're receiving as well as to Allen
Monroe and especially to Barbara silifke
- for holding this all together thank
you very much